remember memory cards yeah stuff have
you ever had like a save file that's
just been corrupt
actually trauma from my childhood of
like my [ __ ] gamecube ones just like
dying for no reason all the [ __ ]
games the
because i bought the madcatz ones
back in the day mad cats was like
everything like if you wanted a
controller or another memory card or any
peripheral yeah that was half the price
mad cats so like we have the we have
like the xbox now and now uh not the
xbox sorry the gamecube in our uh room
right now and i was like okay i gotta
buy some memory cards for it yeah i just
and like the trauma kicked back the
moment i said that to myself i was like
we gotta buy memory cards we got to buy
memory cards i just ended up buying like
10 memory cards because i was like i'm
just expecting the worst yeah one of
these memory cards gonna die in like two
days guaranteed luckily it hasn't
happened yet so i just have this like
pile of memory cards in my room that are
just unused just in case but yeah yeah i
remember it was it sucked as well
because it was like there was no pattern
to it no there wasn't there was never a
it was just like one day the memory card
was like
yeah
yeah i think playing with memory cards
uh on the gamecube has given me a
permanent fear of playing jrpgs like
like it was like you know
mario kart you know [ __ ] any zelda
game okay zelda's bad enough okay yeah
oh dude like i've had some wind waker
accounts just completely dying on me for
no reason but there is nothing worse
than a [ __ ] jrpg corrupting and i've
had it i've had on gamecube i've had it
on ps2 i still have never finished star
ocean three because i've i've gotten
[ __ ] 60 hours into the game i was
invested and then the memory card got
corrupted and i just lost 60 hours of my
life i i and i've never gotten it back
and i don't know what the ending of that
game is i i i had it even worse once i
think it was like the the second time i
played uh a final fantasy game i was
playing final fantasy 6 for the first
time on super nintendo and i was like 40
hours in i think i was like maybe like
two bosses away
and uh and just one of my cousins walked
past
kicked the snes and
flicked it back on
corrupt all gone yeah and i was like i i
had i've never been that close to
committing murder in my life
but i was that close like eight-year-old
mia was like
is is this how like serial murders start
joey was a good boy until the day
until he wasn't until that day when
someone kicked his sneakers
and then i realized and then that's when
i realized just the
the absolute fragility of these like old
consoles that literally just a tiny it
wasn't even like a boot it was like
literally just like a little it was it
was either you you had like an absolute
tank or you got very unlucky and one tap
did it like i i swear to god i dropped
my nintendo ds like a million times the
child oh dude those things are brick
[ __ ] houses yeah but i heard never broke
yeah but somehow you know my my ps2
would just [ __ ] itself all the time
but i swear everyone else's ps2 was a
tank so i i don't really like like for
some reason like they're always like the
sony ones well just like the most
fragile things compared like being a
nintendo switch 360s i've seen like how
those things survive i don't even know
man even though the red ring of death
like yeah yeah
i know like do you remember did you ever
have that experience on a ps2 where you
you know you you go up to the loading
screen and then you put the disc in and
you just like you're praying for like a
few seconds of silence you're praying to
god that you're going to get the
zhu yeah yeah yeah
and it's and when you don't you have
this like it's like this [ __ ] hellish
dimension right where where the ps2 just
turns into like the gates of like the
[ __ ] gates of hell opened up it's all
red you're just like oh i've got a
corrupt disk oh no
how do you even do that how do you get a
corrupt disk how does that even happen
ah how do you not do that i'm sure have
you never have you never open like had a
had a [ __ ]
like xboxes like if that was like one
like micro meter oh actually oh they're
being scratched yeah no not even a
scratch if there's like just a tiny bit
of dust on it it just wouldn't run i
remember there was like disc cleaning
services at like game stores
and uh really yeah yeah in the uk and
they just didn't [ __ ] work like at
all like you paid like 30 pounds yeah
which is like the cost of a game at that
time right and you'd get like two
disspec and then she didn't didn't do
anything it didn't work they'd be like
yeah it's good to go i'm like no it's
not i put it in did you even try it no
yeah it worked i'm like coffee didn't
that's why i like the you know like the
super nintendo cartridges right because
it's like if it didn't work cartridges
are pretty nice fall on that [ __ ] like
smack it against the wall if you want
you pop it in and it magically works oh
so
speaking of the cartridges things you
should never do yeah um i remember how
like i had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it was like you know you
know some kids are just [ __ ]
absolutely no reason yeah so we had like
this uh we had like this distant
relative friend who like yeah she's no
longer a friend no no no you're you'll
hear this story
you'll hear the story and you guys like
you know you know family unions
especially asian family unions they're
like some kids there some people that
you don't know how you're related to all
your families related to but it's like a
family friend cousin and they're always
[ __ ] worse so i remember we were like
playing goldeneye on the n64 but he
chose our job didn't he huh but he chose
no no he didn't no no no he he didn't do
that uh he he got he got smacked he got
smashed he got batted and he was a
pretty good scorer yeah we we scored him
it was four before it was uh it was a
four player game yeah he died
immediately yeah he he got humiliated
and what did he do
he just went over to the n64 and just
took the cartridge out
no
no turning off the console no nothing
just took the cartridge that's a big no
no you can't do that
you know the you know the debate of like
whether people can be born evil or
whether they learn it like i'm just like
clearly kids are born evil like i'm
clearly just witnessing johann lee bird
right here
there are some kids that you're like you
you who
you must have been born with the sunrise
he came out the womb of boston i thought
that was [ __ ] music playing when you
came out the [ __ ]
like final fantasy boss music yeah
it's like for some like as a kid as i'm
sure you can understand as well like
yeah as a gaming kid right there was
like you could punch me you could you
could spit on me you could stamp me but
you don't touch the game console no
that's a big no no you don't doesn't
matter how heated [ __ ] gets you stay
away from the people that's sacrilegious
that's like that's like the stuff that
you i i was i was a calm kid at times
but the one thing that would set me off
it's like you touched the game console
while it's on that's yeah i'm a loser
okay who you are yeah one of my biggest
pet peeves as a kid whenever i play with
like a mate or something or whenever i
have mates over is for some reason
everyone had [ __ ] greasy hands and
their controllers would grease up their
hands would grease up my controller
for the dual shock ps2 controller yeah
like like my biggest pet peeve was when
you know when we were having food or
something we had pizza and they would
they would be eating the pizza while
playing the game and i could say
get a wet wipe please
and i could see their greasy hands going
on the controller and i'm just like you
know what maybe friendship's overrated
this this is why i played the
performance of grease in like in between
like the button and the controller
that's why you know when people grab
pizza and there is kitchen all available
i'm like you absolute animal why didn't
you that was a perfectly good kitchen
roll on the table why do you not take a
slice yeah you know for the crumbs or
just to wipe your hands on you know this
is pizza it's greasy come on
yeah please please learn some manners
especially as adults because i feel like
even even as adults there's some people
who don't do that as well and i don't
know greasy controllers are just like
one of my biggest pet peeves yeah it's
pretty disgusting because it's kind of
hard to clean it yeah it is
yeah
gross i was gonna say something i
totally forgot